I figured out a way to hack Parkinson's
log Parkinson's law states that work
expands so as to fill the time available
for its completion which basically means
the amount of time you think you have to
complete something is how long it will
take you to complete that thing so if
you have a project due in three months
you'll probably end up taking three
months to finish it well it's more like
you'll do almost nothing for two and a
half months and then cram it all in
during the last couple of weeks the same
thing can be applied to all your dreams
and Ambitions in life see I've always
been a pretty paranoid person to the
point where every time I go on a plane I
vividly imagine it crashing the fact
that I will die does not make me cower
in a corner somewhere I understand that
it's unavoidable which makes me want to
experience as much of the world as
possible before my time is up and
because I feel like I don't have much
time left it causes me to take action
every single day that's how you max out
Parkinson's law follow us for more
helpful tips